[Music]
in Disney movies we get to see our
favorite princesses finally find their
happily ever after but not much is known
about their lives once these movies come
to an end
aren't you curious to see what Elsa
tiana Arielle and the rest of the
princesses are up to now well we found
the photos from the next stage of their
lives
motherhood you won't believe what their
kids look like especially married as
bundles of joy if you're new to our
channel make sure to subscribe and give
us a big thumbs up today we'll be
showing you the adorable photos of 10
Disney princesses free imagined as
parents Elsa Queen Elsa doesn't ride off
into the sunset with her handsome King
once frozen comes to an end however that
doesn't mean this Disney character lived
the rest of her royal life all alone
thankfully an artist by the name of
Isaiah Stephens has given us a glimpse
into else's life as a mother and we must
say she's handling motherhood perfectly
in this photo
Elsa is spending some quality time with
her little baby boy the look in her eyes
is priceless she's beaming with joy and
so much pride motherhood really
completes her don't you think and her
beautiful baby boy has all of Elsa's
features including her big blue eyes and
her wispy blond hair but not only that
it appears that else's son was also born
with the unique ability to make ice and
snow just check out the little snow
flurries coming from his tiny little
hand it just warms our hearts to see
Elsa all grown up and embracing this new
stage of her life and looking at this
photo really makes us wonder who her
king is wouldn't it be awesome if Disney
released a new movie that's focused on
else's life as a wife and mom we think
so Arielle Disney fans were already
introduced to Ariel's daughter melody in
the film The Little Mermaid to return to
the sea but judging by these artists
renditions our favorite mermaid and
Prince Erik decided to expand their
family after Ariel gave birth to melody
and now they're a family of four in this
photo the artists Linnea iceberg created
a stud
family portrait of Ariel Eric melody and
baby pontus just like most of the
character names in The Little Mermaid
Pontus was named after the pre Olympian
see God in Greek mythology they all look
so happy and content as they hang around
in the sea but if you think this picture
is breathtaking
you ain't seen nothing yet we have
another photo of aerial and pontus that
really tug at your heartstrings artist
Isiah Stephens created this candid
moment between Ariel and her little baby
boy in the photo the mermaid is feeding
her royal prince but it looks like he's
more focused on having a food fight
instead thankfully Ariel is able to keep
her composure and erased the joys of
motherhood no matter how messy things
may get her little boy looks like a
handful doesn't he we wonder where he
gets his playful nature from Cinderella
Cinderella's early childhood was
heartbreaking
she was forced to be raised by her evil
stepmother and she spent most of her
childhood cleaning and scrubbing floors
instead of being a real kid but we
always knew deep down in our hearts that
Cinderella would grow up to be an
amazing mother
we know she would never dream of
treating her own child in such a cruel
and unfair way in the film she's always
so kind and patient despite her rocky
upbringing she would never even harm a
fly or a mouse for that matter we're
curious to see what her life is like
after marrying the love of her life and
having a baby how about you well the
artist
Linnea has answered our wishes once
again in this photo Cinderella her
prince and their son are having a bit of
fun outside the palace he's the spitting
image of his father don't you think what
do you think they named their little boy
well according to the artist his name is
Jacob he was named after one of the
co-authors of the original Cinderella
fairy tale we're so happy the princess
is now able to live a calm and peaceful
life surrounded by nothing but love
Mulan
it looks like Mulan is finally ready to
step away from the warrior life she's
leaving the battling behind to embrace a
brand new adventure
she and Shang had a bumpy relationship
in the film Mulan - but it looks like
they're back on track they're now
happier than ever bringing peace the two
chinese kingdoms these days the couple
is embarking on a journey to become
parents in this photo from the artist
Isaiah it looks like Mulan is in the
final stages of her pregnancy and just
take a look at her face she's absolutely
glowing
she looks so calm and relaxed we
definitely think she's ready for all
that will come along with motherhood it
also helps that Shang is there with her
every step of the way he looks so proud
that the love of his life will be giving
birth to their mini warrior if they have
a boy we expect he'll be just as great
of a leader as his dad but if they have
a girl we're pretty sure she'll be bold
a confident and brave just like Mulan
Parenthood will be one of the hardest
battles of their lives but we don't have
any doubt that these two lovebirds will
be amazing parents Merida Merida is the
only Disney princess who doesn't have
any sisters but we're sure she didn't
mind one bit growing up she was raised
with her triplet brothers Harris Hubert
and Hamish these three little boys were
always full of mischief like the time
they were caught fiddling with the
trophies in fergus's trophy room Merida
was probably looking forward to the day
when she was an adult and living out on
her own without her annoying little
brothers pestering her but triplets
obviously run in Merida's family so it's
really no surprise that now she's all
grown up she's the mother of triplets
- this drawing was created by an artist
named cabe Escalante
it looks like motherhood is really
getting the best of Merida doesn't it
she's potty training her triplets and
instead of using the potty they decided
to scribble their self portraits on the
wall instead these little girls
definitely take after their uncles but
the best part about Merida having three
brothers is they give her a little break
by stepping in and taking turns
babysitting the little girls
we hope Parenthood gets easier for
Merida as her triplets get a bit older
but for now they're definitely giving
her a hard time
Jasmine next up we have Princess Jasmine
artist Isaiah once again put his
imagination to the test by creating an
amazing reimagined photo in the film
Jasmine fell head-over-heels for Aladdin
who's far from being a royal despite
their two different upbringings aladdin
and Jasmine fell in love and now they're
about to be parents since they come from
two walks of life we think their
personalities will mix together
perfectly their child is bound to have
all of their amazing personality traits
from Jasmine's free spiritedness to
Aladdin's kind-hearted nature in this
photo of the loving couple jasmine looks
as beautiful as ever she is ditched her
midriff-baring outfits for a beautiful
tank top and a flowing skirt but she's
still looking as stylish as ever with
her matching headband and her flawless
makeup and just look at the excitement
on Aladdin space he can't wait to be a
dad and hold his new baby in his arms
aside from having two awesome parents
their new baby will also have a friend
in Jasmine's pet tiger Raja we're sure
he will be fiercely protective of the
family's new bundle of joy Tiana with
two caring and supportive parents in her
life it's no wonder tiana grew up
wanting to be an amazing parent to the
main character and the princess and the
frog had all the traits of a good mother
she was hardworking an awesome cook and
very kind to everyone she came in
contact with we always wondered what
Tiana and Prince navin's lives would be
like after their Disney fairy tale came
to an end
thankfully we don't have to wonder any
longer the artist Linnea has created a
beautiful portrait of Tiana and her
family are you ready to see it
well here it is how cute does the couple
look as they play with their beautiful
baby girl in the Bayou they're all
decked out and they're all green outfits
and they're looking as happy as ever
their baby girl also appears to be
wearing a miniature sized version of
Tiana's iconic green ball gown now
that's what we call twinning according
to the artist the baby girl's name is
Stella which means star and Stella is
absolutely the star of this family and
the apple of her parents eye
Rapunzel in the movie Tangled Rapunzel
is forced to live her life behind the
walls of the tower and she's convinced
that only bad things happen in the
outside world in the film
Rapunzel sang the song when will my life
begin well the answer is now long gone
are the days when the princess was bored
of her dull life as depicted by the
artist Isaiah Rapunzel is now an adult
and living life with her new family
we already saw Elsa beaming with pride
of her little boy and Mulan glowing in
her last stages of pregnancy however
Rapunzel is experiencing the Messier
side of motherhood in this image she's
changing her baby's diaper while her
hubby Flynn Rider ducks for cover
while Rapunzel is handling this typical
mommy duty like a champ
Flynn is doing his best to mask the
stench with a gas mask strapped to his
face well he better get used to the
smell of dirty diapers because it looks
like Rapunzel is enjoying every minute
with her new baby we wouldn't be
surprised if the couple decided to add
on to their family by having another and
another and another with her natural
healing powers her baby doesn't have to
worry about any cuts or bruises while
learning how to ride a bike when they
get older and the child doesn't have to
worry about making new friends any time
soon
they instantly gained a BFF through
Rapunzel's closest friend
Pascale Pocahontas Pocahontas this life
journey was far from over when the
Disney film came to an end in 1998
Disney released a sequel called
Pocahontas to journey to a new world and
it depicted an unfortunate ending to the
princess and John Smith's romance in the
movie John Smith went missing Pocahontas
was upset but she was forced to move on
with her life she set out on a voyage to
England to meet with King James and
that's where she met a man named John
Ralph later on in the film John Smith is
finally located and he begs for
Pocahontas to run away with him but as
the same goes it was too little too late
Pocahontas fell in love with John Rolfe
and they moved to Jamestown to start
their lives together now that we've got
that out of the way we have a photo of
Pocahontas
we can't wait to show you are you ready
to see what she looks like as a mom well
take a look at her now isn't this photo
absolutely beautiful the new mom is
catching some Z's while her baby naps in
her arms
they look so calm and peaceful together
we're sure Pocahontas is a wonderful
mommy and if she ever needs any
parenting device or guidance she can
always turn to grandmother willow
snow-white we couldn't make this video
without including one of the most
popular princesses of them all Snow
White she may be one of the youngest
Disney Princesses in the lineup but
she's wise beyond her years
Snow White has a calm and quiet
personality that makes her a favorite
amongst her furry friends and the Seven
Dwarfs
we're positive that not only would she
make a good wife to the prince
but we know she'd make a great mother to
the artist Linnea osburgh decided to
completely recreate Snow White and
turned her into a dotty mom are you
ready to see what her life is like now
well here she is
in this picture the princess is holding
on tight to her baby while her prince
looks at them both with so much love in
his eyes but take a look at their
adorable little girl she looks like Snow
White's identical twin she has the same
jet-black hair the same wide and
expressive eyes and identical rosy
cheeks according to the artist the
baby's name is ADA which means kind and
we're sure she'll grow up to be just as
kind as her mom - now that baby ADA has
arrived into the world she has probably
already been greeted by all of Snow
White's friends including the Seven
Dwarfs when the prince and princess are
in need of some alone time we are sure
the divorce wouldn't mind entertaining
the baby for a few hours now that's a
clever movie idea we'd love to see on
the big screen did you enjoy this video
if so don't forget to leave us a comment
and let us know which of the royal
children is your favorite feel free to
subscribe to our channel to see more
amazing content thanks for watching
[Music]